are you able to talk about how you got
financing for the film or it's it was
pretty straightforward once we had the
script dentists is all done
actually I had pitched okay let me let
me let me rewind so when Stefan the
writer and I started working on the
script and the sizzle I I had lunch with
producer friend of mine and I just
briefly gave him the logline
and he's like oh my god that's awesome
when you're done let me see it
and we're good friends and we go back a
few years
also someone I met through a friend that
I went to school with obviously but so
when we were all done my managers sent
it out to a few people a few companies
and I sent it to my producer friend
chatty and he loved it and how did that
go because he he had produced the
pyramid for Fox and so he was in Lebanon
at the time that I sent him this stuff
because the Prima because it was the
Middle Eastern premiere of the pyramid
and at the same time that he was there
this other movie called pocket listing
also premiered in Lebanon that one was
produced by the people that ended up
financing danger one so just because and
so because of chaddy my producer friend
was in Lebanon at the time he decided to
go to the premiere of pocket listing and
that's how he met the financed ears and
they had just finished a movie and they
were looking for something new and they
told him what they were looking for and
chaddy he was like oh my god you should
check this out I got a sizzle and a
script and at that point like things
things moved pretty fast like we
probably spent two months on like
rewriting the script for them and
probably five months later we were we
were on set yeah so you put your own
money for the sizzle and then in the end
and you got someone to finance the film
yeah yeah I wouldn't be able to finance
on an editor salary you're not going to
be able to finance a film
this is yeah pretty cool yeah yeah and
you know our budget wasn't high
especially for a movie this ambitious
and you know was a full union shoot but
uh yeah we we got it we got it done you
think it being mostly interior of or
just in that one warehouse whatever what
they had with the ambulance that that
saved a lot of money so you're not doing
- yeah I mean honestly I don't I don't I
don't know how we got this done with the
time we had and the budget it's a bit of
a miracle and in hindsight I I do think
it would have been good if we had and I
know every director will tell you that
we had a little bit more but we still
had a whole lot of locations that we had
to cover in 23 days so for us to be able
to spend the first I think we spent the
first two weeks of those 23 days in that
warehouse basically covering everything
that happens in the West and also inside
the ambulance was it's the only way to
get that done and then for the last the
next two weeks that's when we kind of
you know head out but we still had so
many locations where it's like you have
a company move in the middle of the day
you're doing one scene here and then
everyone gets in their cars and their
trucks and you travel somewhere else
it's yeah but we also kinda I guess a
lot of the scenes we sort of shot right
around that warehouse the funny thing is
like there's a scene in the movie where
they're getting rid of the firefighters
body in the manhole and we were looking
for a location for that so when we were
in the warehouse the warehouse was
actually a terrible place it's we use it
as a sound soundstage it should not be
used as a soundstage because once it's
sound stages are soundproof right that
makes them a sound stage this is just an
old warehouse but what's worse is
literally like right next to that
warehouse was a recycling plan
oh so we're shooting inside this
warehouse and all night long all day
long you've got like these contained
trucks pushing containers with metal
cans and bottles against our wall which
is why a lot of the sound was unusable
and we have to ADR a lot of it
but we're like well that's that's can we
go take a look at this recycling plant
maybe we can shoot there and that's we
eventually ended up shooting a whole
scene and they're literally just next
door yeah so when when you found out
that a lot of the sound wasn't usable
like how shocking was that maybe you
knew that was coming on yeah well we I
mean we know it was coming because we've
heard it on said once we I mean it was
not a good situation to be and you don't
want to especially in a low-budget film
you don't wanna have to ADR half your
movie but a lot of the stuff that
happened in there yeah we had to get
through ADR and post
we had a long IDR schedule on this movie
how long did that set you back cuz you
probably had an idea that it was gonna
be released by certain time and then it
was the things like our just because
certain things didn't go according to
plan during production a lot of it and
this happens on movies alive the post
production budget kind of moved into
production so when you then get to
post-production you have to be really
smart but things will just take longer
because there's no less money to get it
done than there was before so our our
post oh my god how long how long was
that cuz we shot in 2016 in March and
April and I think the movie was done no
it was were we in post for like a year
probably because at some point actors
are also you know out of town shooting
new things so it's like you have to
start scheduling around you know their
availability
just like the furtive remove that gets
from the actual from principal
photography the hardware it gets but
yeah I think I think we were when we
finished we fin
we finished the film towards the in fall
2017 so yeah post was was a year did you
have all the actors come back in parade
er all the major players yeah I think so
yeah I mean Tom Everett Scott was in for
like four days
yeah even yeah Denis O'Hare had to come
from New York we even had some ad are
done in Lebanon because the actor was in
Lebanon like he had to like visit a
studio there and like you know we have a
Skype call yeah pretty much all the
ultimate replace were in for a day half
a day and some of the smaller ones how
does that work so you've gone through
the entire movie and you know from this
time marker to this the sound is
horrible and this line needs to be done
so you're charting all that well yeah I
wasn't but the the supposed sound
Department they were they basically just
and there was the first time I had done
that they basically just give you a long
list of like here's a timecode here's
the line get this line the good thing
about it is it actually allows you to
tweak the performance a little bit - now
I know a lot of actors don't like ADR
and I get it because you're in a booth
and it doesn't feel you know being on
set there's the environment and you can
really get into it you've got a the
other character in front of you you're
you're having an actual interaction it
allows you to you know get out of your
head and really just get be in that
moment ADR you're in a padded tiny booth
by yourself like the acting just becomes
the acting experience becomes very
artificial and you're just saying the
line over and over again and it loops a
lot of actors hate doing it as a
director or just for the post crew it
allowed us to like tweak certain
performances to like even out the tone a
little bit you know take certain things
down a notch also to actually rewrite
certain lines that were off camera
because like scenes might have gotten
cut there's I think a couple scenes that
we never even shot so it's like we have
to like you know somehow get that
content in which ADR is just the best
way of doing that so you know so it
wasn't just replacing crappy production
audio it was also just tweaking the
story okay sorry so how do you get that
to to match to match the room tone of
the bad sound that's in Vernon that
probably has a very distinct feel and
then you
this pristine booth how is that working
um well Monday during the mixed day what
we there's an ADR an ADR editor so they
already do some filtering on it and then
during the mix you make it you try to
make it sound as much as possible as
production sometimes they just advised
you to ADR the whole scene because
they're like we're never gonna be able
to match this if you know what lines are
ad are you can tell like I hear when I
watch it I'm like there's an 80 yard
line right there I don't know if
audiences can but yeah it's it's it's
it's not easy right so you you know it
just because you know there was more
reverb or whatever you could just hear
more of an echo or something yeah
this was too crisp but most of the time
the audience will know well now having
done it I can actually also hear it in
other movies I would watch a movie even
on like big movies you're like that's an
ADR line right there you have an
editor's ear though well I mean in
reality TV well I guess we do some of
that but it's you know it's not on this
level like ADR in reality TV is talent
we'll say it into their iPhone and
record it and then like text it over
it's not done it's not quite on the same
level as on a feature but then too with
a lot of reality TV there's music
playing almost the entire time it seems
like yeah under the under that so so
that would probably filter a lot yeah
yeah there's a lot of it it's just
wall-to-wall yeah yeah yeah yeah but no
I mean a reality TV you you do quite a
bit of wild lines you know look if
dialogue cheated underneath that people
again recording their iPhones or like
tearing during interviews and then you
make it you know we make it sound like
it's actually happening in scene yeah
like I said not a lot of reality in
reality TV sure I mean iPhone audio and
sound excellent
so yeah well because audio on in reality
TV is are very kind of crappy so like
the audio from the iPhone is gonna fit
in nice you know yeah it's not gonna
stand out that much
you